12h02 cessez-le-feu pour évacuer
certaines zones bombardées le résultat
des dernières discussions russo
ukrainienne confirmé ce matin à kiev oui
autres moines à paris nous avons reçu
une notification de la fédération de
russie concernant l'approbation de nos
itinéraires précédemment proposé et tu
vises kobe pour aux joûtes sa propre
unité volet militaire accès de cessez le
feu de 9h 7 à 21h ce jour est née
potoczny n'ya
en tout six couloirs humanitaires
doivent permettre l'évacuation des
populations
l'un d'entre eux est censée laisser les
habitants de villes situées à l'ouest de
kiev rejoindre la capitale mais des tirs
d'artillerie qui seraient toujours en
cours les cinq autres couloirs se trouve
dans l'est du pays notamment au départ
de marioupol ville portuaire au sud est
assiégée et pilonnée depuis la semaine
dernière là où les tentatives
précédentes de cessez le feu et
d'évacuation de civils ont échoué les
deux parties s'en renvoyant la
responsabilité
trois cent mille personnes attendaient
de pouvoir s'en aller a soumis ville du
nord proche de la frontière russe
également concerné par le cessez le feu
environ 5000 personnes ont pu être
transportés mardi dans le centre du pays
à bord d'une soixantaine de bus de son
côté moscou affirme que des progrès ont
été réalisés au niveau des négociations
humanitaire mais continue de défendre
l'idée d'une évacuation des populations
de l'est de l'ukraine vers son
territoire
environ deux millions de personnes ont
demandé à être évacués vers la russie et
140 mille sont déjà entrés en territoire
russe
des chiffres impossibles à vérifier
tout comme l'authenticité des images
diffusées par le ministère russe de la
défense celle ci montre des
distributions d'aidé humanitaire dans la
région de kharkiv